just supervise will be looking at this
idea of exponential growth UK right one
of the things we haven't really gone and
done or I haven't at least you guys I
think I've looked with some questions
that the past you to do this is we have
not plotted these okay now i just want
to remind you about this before you move
on to decay because i didn't address
decay situations at all yesterday i'll
do a couple of unit for this morning
what does this look like well because
it's an exponential and i'll just put
the both of the common forms here
because it doesn't matter whether its
capital a or p naught they both refer to
your initial condition right what does
the graph look like well we're super
familiar with what Exponential's look
learn right so this is the kind of shape
this is the kind of behavior that we're
getting okay as a few features that are
missing from here what else could I add
to make this sketch a little more
accurate I could add intercept right
what is the intercept it's either a or
penal whichever you define it to be okay
so let's call it a for now since my
first one is there anything else I look
to add on there I suppose it would be
nice to have a point scale bit arbitrary
at the moment because it's all sort of
constants that we have no idea what they
are okay there is one other feature if I
just asked you nothing to do with
exponential growth in the K just to draw
this thing just to graph it okay there's
one glaring feature that's mrs. can
anyone tell me what it is the asymptote
isn't it so it should be here across the
T axis okay now while we're talking
about the T axis it's probably important
to mention that you'll notice I have the
left-hand side and the right hand side
the T actions i have negative values for
T and positive value since fatigue ok
now we used to think about sort of
measurements being positive only right
you don't tell me why it actually is
kind of worthwhile to have both sides of
the T axis any suggestions
excuse me let me ask posed this question
of the origin right T equals zero have a
think about some of the questions that
you've had a look out already what does
T equals zero signify usually or can
anyone think of any examples it's your
initial value right now often they will
say you know in a year nineteen
ninety-five or something like that and
they say we call this the initial value
and they give you a population okay but
of course we know that's why we call
tonight 35 the time doesn't just start
order the universe just started just
take him back to 95 there was tied
before that okay the questions you've
been looking at they mostly have just
been thinking about progression but if
this model works if it's consistent
right if the situation there have given
to us matches this exponential growth
curve then we should be able to just as
easily go back in time right you could
say well 1935 75 in this scheme would be
a t-value are negative 20 right million
20 something like that which is totally
sensible it's it's it's it's a sensible
value makes sense ok so don't trust them
if you've been drawing your rafts and
you've been riding off the negative side
of the T axis add that back in now or
for subsequent graphs you've got plenty
more to draw ok now beta this is an
exponential growth situation what does
an exponential decay situation look like
what's the difference in terms of the
equations there's a negative where's
where's the negatives it's up in the
index isn't it so to be something like
this ok now we're used to seeing you
know e to the x and e to the minus X
right IDO negative x having that
negative sign there it flips things
around horizontally cuz of it ok so this
is the shape we're getting
okay yeah just like before this is why I
was drawing attention to the asymptotes
okay just like we have an asymptote hear
the accent is exactly the same okay
sorry we bit off the access there so
that's 0 now this is important because
let's see if we can describe what's
going on here in terms of our
exponential growth and decay language
right we know why algebraically why this
never gets to zero right because no
matter what large values of T you stick
in there right for example if i put in
100 okay you're going to get a e to the
negative 100 k which is a on e to the
100k right which depending on your value
of k is probably a really small number
right but it's not zero and if i went
further if I went like time a million
something like that that's right you're
still going to get a very very very
small number did I just put too many
zeros no that's okay right but you'll
never get 20 algebraically because
there's no value you can stick in the
denominator right that will make the
whole thing equal to 0 i canna that's
fine algebraically but can you explain
to me in terms of the language of
exponential growth and decay why is it
that he never gets to zero like in the
population or the quantity or the mass
or whatever it is why can't it ever get
to zero hmm
because it's impossible why is it
impossible um you wanna do our house I
guess ok let's go after this what is the
the differential equation you remember
I'm introduced that idea really it's a
um it's a first order differential
equation i wonder if you can guess what
second order differential equation with
the play where think about this for now
we're thinking decay so that's why
there's a minus sign up front because
when i differentiate is the negative
will pop out the front just like the k
does right now this is proportionality i
did yesterday i said if you understand
this everything about exponential gretna
k will make sense ok the rest of it is
just number crunching I think I what
this means okay as you get further along
in terms of time right a thousand years
a million years or those kinds of things
right what can you tell me about the
population or the mass or the quantity
what does it look like well yeah the
actual population sells very small isn't
it very very very small ok now the
population small what that implies is
that the rate that the population is
changing or the rate that the mass is
changing or whatever quantity it is it's
also getting smaller right it's getting
smaller at the same rate that's what
proportional means ok so the closer and
closer you get to zero the more you're
slowing down right does that make sense
the less stuff there is the less the
rate of change will be and that's why
you never get 20 okay so I want you to
be able to understand and interpret and
explain what's going on here not just in
terms of this language but the fact that
you know what did they stand for this
stand for quantities and populations and
people and so on